mark Pendergrast author of uncommon
grounds the history of coffee and how it
transformed our world in the back of the
book you run a number in your book 800
go geo Britt Bri tt why did you do that
why'd you why'd you pass that on to the
audience well you know I'm somebody who
believes in telling people how to get at
things if I talk about them for instance
I also ran the fax number of the roaster
the Palani roaster guy where you can for
three dollars buy this aluminum pie
plate that has holes punched in it you
can roast your own coffee so I'm just
trying to be user-friendly basically
what you're referring to is cafe Britt
which is a roaster in Costa Rica and I
ended the book with him fairly
deliberately because you know that this
is this is going to be a little bit of a
long answer to your question but coffee
beans are grown in the tropics in
relatively poor countries and then the
beans once they're processed the green
beans they're called before they're
roasted I don't think most people have
seen them but they look like little
peanuts they're kind of greenish blue
peanut looking things and when they're
roasted they blow up to twice their size
and they become the roasted coffee that
you and I both know and love well once
it's roasted a time bomb starts to tick
once it's roasted if oxygen gets to it
its tails it very quickly so ideally
coffee should be ground and brewed
within a week or two of it being roasted
and that means that traditionally the
people who actually grow the coffee
don't really make all that much money
off of it certainly the people who
harvest the coffee are very very poor
most of the time and get very little of
the added value and most of that value
comes after it is roasted when it's
roasted and I gave a plug deliberately
to Cafe Britt because this guy is
roasting it right there in Costa Rica
and he's adding money and value right
there and you can call this 800 number
from North America and you
actually reach someone in Costa Rica and
they will send you the coffee and the
way that they can keep it relatively
fresh is number one they send it right
out and I'm not trying to give them a
plug but there there's something called
a one way valve bag now where it will
let air out but not in and it really
does help preserve the coffee for longer
and they use those kinds of bags I
wanted to encourage this sort of thing
where we're not in the developed world
the only ones who are making most of the
money off of this I tried very hard in
the book not to take any kind of
moralizing tone I tried to just present
the facts throughout 99% of the book but
in the final chapter you know after 400
or so pages I figured I had earned the
right to sort of have my say in one of
my sales was just that let me go back to
the number it's 800 G Oh Brit Bri tea
tea if you call that number from the
United States you pay tax do we do pay
reservation number
no no somebody ships through these beans
do they pay tax on is you avoid tax this
way now I don't think you avoid tax I
think you have to pay tax on it do you
avoid paying the middle person all the
way through the process yes yes and how
many middle people are there in this
game they're quite a few middle people
in this game usually there's somebody
who exports the coffee and he has to
deal with shippers and everything then
there's somebody who who imports the
coffee who's different from the exporter
then there's you know there are all
kinds of people who test the beans along
the way there's the coffee exchange
where the prices are set there are the
Roasters there are the retailers who
sell the roasted beans and there are the
coffee houses that sell it brewed there
are the supermarket's
there are the warehouses it's like you
know any other product except for the
fact that it's you know coffee grows on
volcanic Mountain sides usually between
about 3,000 and 6,000 feet high in the
tropics where the
temperature never varies too much out of
the 70s and 70 degrees Fahrenheit or so
so they're beautiful places but they're
quite remote to just take it from the
very beginning the coffee tree actually
is native to Ethiopia and then it spread
from Ethiopia across the Red Sea to
Yemen and the Arabs tried to keep a
monopoly for quite some time they
finally lost that monopoly the the there
was an Indian pilgrim named Bob Abu Don
who reputedly strapped seven seas to his
stomach and took them to India then the
Dutch got hold of some plants and
planted them in Java a French lieutenant
got hold of a coffee tree and took it
across the Atlantic to Martinique and
from that tree most of the coffee that
we drank from the Western Hemisphere
descended so it takes about four years
for a seedling to grow to the point
where it's a tree that's bearing enough
berries to get the coffee and the coffee
berry is called a cherry usually it's
red when it's ripe although I've seen
varieties when I was in Central America
that were yellow but most of them are
red and they have to be hand-picked at
least the best ones are hand-picked so
that you avoid getting the ones that
aren't quite ripe then they have to be
processed immediately the skin is taken
off of them what's called the Musil edge
which is the sort of fruity part which
by the way tastes rather sweet if you
chew it that has to come off and it
doesn't want to come off the bean it's
sort of like very sticky so in the wet
process they ferment it deliberately for
a very strict limited period of time
usually about 24 hours and then it will
wash off and then the beans have to be
very carefully dried so there's a lot to
the processing of the beans before they
even get exported even once the Musil
age is taken off there's some
and call the parchment which is the sort
of thick skin that's on them that has to
be taken off and then there's a little
very thin tissue paper called the silver
skin and they try to get most of that
off but a lot of that turns into what's
called shaft during the roasting process
so it's really a complicated business
there's a lot that I want to ask you
about including the guy you found that
drinks 50 cups of coffee a day or did
you find him
Joe McBratney he he owns a wonderful
restaurant on Staten Island it's called
the Kreischer mansion and I highly
recommend his muscles but I found him
from a 20/20 show on television it was a
show on caffeine and on it's addictive
qualities and they showed Joe and on
television he appeared to be quite a
calm person and so I was intrigued I
thought she somebody who drinks it's the
equivalent of 50 cups by the way I just
I just mailed Joe a cup about this size
as sort of a joke because I found one
it's bigger than this is huge
and he drinks out of cups about this big
so it's the equivalent of 50 regular
cups that he drinks this is water by the
way and the you know this is a network
that spends most of the time talking
about what government does and laws and
all that you mentioned caffeine has the
government ever tried to ban caffeine in
this country well it came close to it in
1912 the government actually sued Coca
Cola in Chattanooga was a huge lawsuit I
wrote about this in a previous book but
I also wrote about it in this one they
went after caffeine in the big way it
essentially around the turn of the last
century caffeine was extremely
controversial in large measure because
of a fellow named CW post that we might
want to talk about in a little bit I
wrote a whole chapter about him and post
him but there was a fellow named Harvey
Wiley who was the father of the Pure
Food and Drug Acts in 1906 and Harvey
Wiley hated Coca Cola interestingly
enough he didn't hate coffee so much he
was opposed to anything he thought was
unnatural and he thought that Coca Cola
was deliberately adding this drug and
was selling it to children that's what
bothered him the most
whereas coffee it was a natural
stitch 1 but they had scientists on all
sides of the issue debating this and
eventually coca-cola one on the lower
courts but then lost higher up and they
sort of did a settlement out-of-court
they agreed to reduce the amount of
caffeine and coca-cola at that point
some quick basics where do you live
Vermont Essex Junction Vermont you
mentioned that uncommon grounds the name
of your book is also the name of a
coffee shop in Burlington Vermont yes as
a matter of fact the picture of me in
the back of the book was taken in that
fine coffee house there's another one
owned by the same people in Saratoga
Springs there's another one that just
opened up in Watertown Massachusetts
when I went out to on my book tour to
Berkeley California there's a roaster II
out there very fine roast recalled
uncommon grounds they came they gave me
a t-shirt they gave me some of their
coffee so I think they're uncommon cuts
all over the country how long did you
work on your book three years what gave
you the idea to do it well you know I
told you I'd written for God country in
coca-cola before this and that book was
about the same length it was you know
quite quite an interesting story about
how a rather in essential product you
know 99% sugar water basically became
the world's most widely distributed
product and this is a similar kind of
intriguing story I like the paradox of
the fact that this is just really it's
the pit of a very of an obscure
understory shrubs trees you want to call
it well it's the second most valuable
exported commodity on earth after oil
now think about that that's amazing and
although you know if the whole world
were deprived of coffee tomorrow we
would all have a gigantic withdrawal
headache but after a few days we would
all be okay we don't need coffee it
doesn't provide any nutrition to speak
of and yet it's become central to our
lives as long ago as over a hundred
years ago someone said you know this is
become the indispensable beverage and
arguably it changed the course of
civilization in many ways for the good
and for the bad how many cups of coffee
on average is an American drink every
day I think it's a little over one now
it's not all that many it's interesting
the per capita consumption of coffee
actually peaked if you do it in pounds
per capita in 1946 right after World War
Two at about 20 pounds per person and
now it's almost it's about half that
it's about ten pounds per person so it's
been declining ever since World War two
it is now leveled out that's what the
specialty industry has done you know
we've sort of rediscovered quality
coffee from origin now and and it's
halted the decline and it may begin to
go up a little bit why do the Finns
drink the most coffee of anybody in the
world that's a good question and how
many more pounds a year per capita they
use over there in Finland than we do
here in the United States I'd have to
look it up I don't remember exactly I
remember the figure of twenty eight
pounds a year that's right blue fans
you've read it more recently than I 28
pounds per capita I think it's correct
well it's awful cold up there and they
also the Scandinavians don't use any
robusta they use only the bet there's
two kinds of coffee bean one is called
Arabica and one is robusta up until a
hundred years ago no one ever used
anything but Arabica and it's by far the
superior type of coffee what happened
was there was something called Himalaya
vest Astrix this otherwise known as the
coffee leaf rust it's a fungus which
attacks coffee and it wiped out the
industry in the East Indies at the in
the last century robusta grows at a
lower altitude it will withstand much
more heat it's also disease resistant it
will stand up to the leaf rust the
trouble is it doesn't taste very good
and it has twice the caffeine and so in
this country after World War two we
began to put first robusta into instant
coffee which became popular
during the sort-of 1950s convenience
crazy
along with Minute Rice and TV dinners
and then we started putting robusta into
our regular blends more and more
especially as the price went up and we
can talk about those price hikes have
been in a minute too but the the
Scandinavians never did that and I think
that because they appreciate really good
coffee they drink a lot of it when you
walk into any place any store whether it
be a specialty store be a grocery store
what would be robust to coffee that you
could pick up off the shelf it's not
going to say this contains robusta
unless it says 100% Arabica it will
contain some robusta what has the most
robust in it
I'm not going to name a brand I think
the cheaper the blend is the more robust
it will have in it alright and I want to
ask you about the names anyway Folgers
coffee mm-hmm would that have a lot of
robust in it well it depends Folgers
puts out a lot of different coffees for
instance if it says 100% Colombian they
won't have any robusta in it so you have
to look at the label on each of them
where did the name folger come from Jim
Folger was a 14 year old who accompanied
his two older brothers who were only I
think 18 and 16 in the during the gold
rush they were from a very famous
whaling family and then tuck it but the
whales were played out and they heard
about this gold in California so they
took ship they left their parents
apparently with their parents blessing I
think this is unbelievable went down to
the Isthmus of Panama of course this is
before the canal went across took ship
up to San Francisco and his two older
brothers tried to mine gold he took up
with somebody who had started a little
coffee roastery and that's how Folgers
began in 1850 in San Francisco chase and
Sanborn who is chase and who was Sanborn
they were both staunch New Englanders
sort of puritanical guys who started
chase and Sanborn in Boston after the
Civil War when most of these brands
began in the late 1800s as we began to
have branded products in general and as
you had
transportation etc do you remember their
first names caleb chase and edward
Sanborn I believe and they were they
were sort of you know they were like Bob
and Ray they they were kind of laid-back
but I enjoyed them
how about Hills brothers where did that
name come from our W and aah Hills were
from Maine originally they came with
their father also all the way across the
country to San Francisco in search of a
better life a little after the gold rush
and they began a small grocery which
evolved into specializing in spices and
in coffee and they they are the first
people who came up with the vacuum can
first they tried they were so they were
supplying a different Gold Rush in the
Yukon in the late 1800s and they were
frustrated because the butter they were
sending out was turning rancid and so
they learned of this place that was
beginning to vacuum-pack butter and they
tried that and they thought well why not
try it on coffee and it's certainly not
as good as a one-way valve but it was a
huge improvement amazingly nobody really
took it up in the East for another 30
years
it was 1931 I think that Maxwell House
started racking canning but it it was
the Hills brothers were you know sort of
staunch New England types
Folgers was also sort of a little
sticking them but most of the coffee
people were I would say rather bland in
their own way they were good business
people they didn't really want women in
the business at all there's a lot about
women's issues in this book what about
Maxwell House where'd that name come
from well Joel cheek was a traveling
salesman he grew up in the hollers the
valleys of Kentucky and he this was when
people in remote areas were still
roasting their own coffee so he was
selling green bean
but he developed his own blend that he
liked and he eventually sold it to the
very prestigious Maxwell House in
Nashville Tennessee and he conned them
because he was a rather good businessman
into letting him call it Maxwell House
coffee in return for giving them a good
deal I imagine and he had I think nine
sons most of whom joined him in the
business I ended up really you know you
get to know these people it's funny I
particularly liked Joel chic because in
an era when it really was not normal to
treat your workers well or to talk about
treating anybody well it was the robber
baron mentality he gave wonderful
speeches which I presume he believed
about how you had to put your arms
around your workers and show them that
you care and get to know their families
and make sure everything was okay with
them and I was impressed by him I was
impressed by his attitude towards family
towards his own family he was also very
clever advertiser when Teddy Roosevelt
came to the Maxwell House and drank a
cup of his coffee I think it was
actually at the Hermitage where he drank
the coffee but he made a big deal out of
the fact that the Miz entered Jackson's
home what's Hermitage yes Andrew
Jackson's home he made a big deal out of
the fact that Teddy Roosevelt's had
drunk his coffee and eventually they
started saying that he had said that it
was good to the last drop which I don't
think he ever said because it was a good
number of years after the incident when
they started to claim this and actually
coca-cola had used the phrase earlier
than they did but nonetheless it's a
terrific phrase and it still is
if you can't can I talk about post them
here for a second because it's yep I
want to come back I just have a couple
quick questions how much coffee do you
drink eBay I drink one or two cups in
the morning one of my favorite reviews
of the book appeared in the
times and the guy viewing it said he'd
never had a cup of coffee in his life
didn't drink it didn't intend to drink
it and then he said and this is a
wonderful book I love this book and that
shows that it really is interesting one
of my frustrations is I've done a lot of
book signings now and people come up and
they'll say well sign the book to my
girlfriend because she loves coffee I
wouldn't be interested in it because I
don't drink coffee
it makes me want to tear my hair out and
say look you know do you only read books
about other social issues or drugs or
whatever if you're if you're a drug
addict I don't understand I mean this is
fascinating topic fascinating history
lots of interesting characters funny
tragic slavery politics lots of Latin
American history why do you have to be a
coffee drinker to drink it where did you
grow up Atlanta Georgia
how long did you live there I lived
there till I was 18 I went to Harvard
and I visit frequently my parents and a
lot of my siblings are still there
what'd you study at Harvard English
literature then what kind of work did
you start doing oh no this is going to
turn into a resume I taught high school
English I taught elementary school I
became a librarian after I got a
master's in library science and all
during that time I was freelance writing
for local papers and then that sort of
graduated to daily papers and then to
magazines but I never figured I would
make a living from it and then I got the
idea to write the book about coca-cola I
did that I wrote a book called victims
of memory which I'm extremely proud of
it's a book about the repressed memory
therapy that harmed so many people in
this country and this is my third major
book when did you move to Vermont 1972
what was the reason for that got a job
teaching elementary school there when'd
you start draining coffee I started
drinking coffee when I was in college at
first it's interesting both of the
caffeinated beverages that I've written
about my parents don't drink and didn't
let us drink
I would sneak coca-cola at friends
houses and I did sneak a little bit of
coffee when I was a kid too you know
heavily diluted with cream and sugar but
I think Freud would probably have a good
time with my choice of topics and when
you did this book how many different
countries did you travel to well I hear
I went to England to do some research in
the International Coffee Organization
and I went to Central America where I
went to five countries during the course
of a month was fascinating phase five
Guatemala Honduras El Salvador Nicaragua
and Costa Rica go back to the number we
gave at the beginning that you have in
the book the 800 go be our ITT again in
Costa Rica how did the bean get there
and if you order directly with them do
you save money no I kind of be do you
get you don't you don't really save
money I don't think it probably cost you
somewhere between 10 and 12 dollars a
pound
for roasted coffee which is you know its
high-end coffee it's very good coffee
its Arabica high grown they call it
strictly hard bean in Costa Rica the
higher it's grown the more dense and
flavorful the bean is and it's got what
they call good acidity and it doesn't
mean it has literally a high pH it has
sort of a snap and brightness to the
bean it's good coffee that there's
another coffee from Costa Rica that I
wrote about also from a farm called la
manisa
which is sort of like a city state a
model place where the guy who owns that
his name bill McAlpin and he prides
himself on paying his workers well and
on obsessively paying attention to the
quality of the beans and the processing
etc so they grow some good coffee there
how did it come to Costa Rica you know
it's interesting the way coffee
developed in Costa Rica as opposed to
for instance Guatemala and El Salvador I
argued in the book has a lot to do with
the form of government that they had
and Costa Rica you know the coffee tree
as I said it came to Martinique and then
it sort of spread from there so it was
in the 1850s 1860s that coffee became a
serious product in Central America and
it was largely it was it was a
combination of factors they'd been
growing something called cochineal which
is a it was a kind of a bug that grows
on cactus and it's a dye and when they
developed a synthetic aniline dyes red
dyes the cochineal industry tanked and
so coffee began to replace it throughout
Central America Costa Rica never had
very many Indians for some reason and
the few they had the early Spanish
settlers either murdered or gave
diseases to and most of them died
whereas in Guatemala for instance there
was a thriving Indian population for
that reason in Guatemala they developed
relatively large coffee plantations and
they forced the Indians to come down out
of the Altiplano the higher places above
where coffee would grow to harvest their
coffee and to work on the farms every
year and for that reason they developed
a repressive military dictatorship to
force the Indians to work it was
basically slave labor same thing
happened in Brazil where it was
literally slave labor they had slaves
until 1888 the longest of anyone in our
hemisphere strictly because of coffee in
Costa Rica because they didn't have a
ready labor force they had much smaller
farms and everybody would help each
other out kind of like a quilting bee
during the harvest season and for that
reason they developed a more egalitarian
democratic form of government and you
can see this you know throughout the
last hundred fifty years
you mentioned the post thing there's
right out here and in the suburbs of
Washington is the Marjorie Merriweather
Post Pavilion mmm who was she Marjorie
Merriweather Post was CW Post
my daughter and he raised her to be a
boy actually he he taught her to fix
cars eventually things like that but CW
post was a sort of neurotic high-strung
inventor invented something called
scientific suspenders I liked those but
he would periodically have nervous
breakdowns and he ended up in the
sanitarium run by John Harvey Kellogg in
Battle Creek Michigan in the late 1800s
and he failed to get better there until
he sort of adopted Christian science but
when he left he started his own Inn in
competition with the sanitarium and he
called it La Veta in and he sort of
espoused a kind of their their version
of New Age it was called new thought and
you could will yourself to get better
and then he invented a fake coffee which
he called Postum after himself he was
rather an egomaniac and it was a copy of
the serial coffee that was made at the
sanitarium but unlike Kellogg he knew
how to advertise and he was absolutely
brilliant at defaming coffee he one of
his headlines was that that eyesight
lost through use of coffee he said that
coffee destroyed your will to live it
destroyed all your organs it kept you
from money and fame everything that went
wrong in your life was due to coffee of
course this drove the coffee people
absolutely mad and it made Post a
millionaire in seven years which was the
fastest that anyone in America had
become a millionaire at that time post
then he claimed by the way that he would
never get ill because he could will
himself to get better and he was
drinking post them in eating Grape Nuts
which he also invented he particularly
claimed that this would cure
appendicitis well then he got
appendicitis and it didn't kill him he
had an operation for it but he fell into
a terrible depression
and he shot himself through the head in
his late 50s leaving Margery his
daughter a millionaire millionairess
many times over she then married EF
Hutton and together they transformed
Poston into General Foods by purchasing
other brands such as jell-o and Maxwell
House which is supreme irony they bought
the best selling coffee in the United
States and made it even more the best
selling coffee
what's in its post them still in grocery
stores yes it is although it's certainly
not a major product anymore what's in it
barley wheat cereals but you know
basically dissident cereals
I've tasted it I think like many such
things it's an acquired taste I don't
care for it myself but many people did
at one time and still do probably
there's a footnote I want to read but I
want to ask you about I am well the book
mm-hmm it did post write that book and
what's it about
yeah CW Post wrote a book where he said
I am well and he was putting himself out
as the ultimate example of the hale and
hearty person that you could become if
you only drank post them and avoided
coffee and he also invented the phrase
the road to wellville.shoot
well that whiskey morphine tobacco
coffee excessive animal passions and
other unnatural conditions contributed
to ill health post knew about animal
passions betting and associates wife and
siring two children by her in 1894 and
1896
yes well post was a man of great great
passions in all always he's an
interesting character he really is that
that chapter is called the drug drink
because that's what he called coffee and
it's one of my favorite chapters in the
book I really enjoyed post which country
in the world supplies the most coffee
Brazil does and it has for a long time
what's the I notice you use a figure of
eighty billion dollars sold a year of
coffee around the world mm-hmm that's
that's an estimate and that includes
coffee sold as a beverage that includes
cappuccinos etc which are a lot of milk
but yeah I estimate it's about eighty
how much of that comes out of Brazil I
don't know in terms of dollar value I
think Brazil you know I have to look it
up
I would guess I going to say I don't
know what percentage of coffee now comes
from Brazil but I do know that they're
the largest coffee producer in the world
and have been for many years their share
has been declining I know that back
around the turn of the last century they
supplied 80% of the coffee in the world
and it's nowhere near that now it's
probably more like 10 or 15 percent of
the coffee in the world which is partly
because they don't rely on coffee so
much anymore which is a good thing for
Brazil being relying on a monoculture is
a recipe for disaster in a world market
where what happened to the Brazilians is
by 1906 they were growing way too much
coffee for people to drink and the price
went way down and they instituted
something called valorisation where they
held coffee off the market and that
worked temporarily but eventually during
the Depression they took to burning
their coffee they burned 78 million bags
of coffee during the Depression and it's
still a problem we have this boom bust
cycle and coffee which I wish I knew a
solution to that I could wave a magic
wand from 1962 to 1989 the United States
agreed to belong to sort of an OPEC of
coffee it was called the international
coffee agreement and we did that for
political reasons we were afraid that if
we allowed the price of coffee to go too
low
that Latin America and Africa would go
communist and I think we may very well
have been correct and so we agreed to
artificially prop up the price of coffee
not too much we just barely kept people
above starvation level because we
wouldn't allow it to go up that much and
then in 1989 when the Cold War was
ending we back out of it and the price
of coffee collapsed for the next four
years under the cost of production it
was horrible
it still is horrible the price of coffee
right now I think is hovering below a
dollar a pound for green beans it's not
enough to live on
when was it the highest probably the
highest for the you know the inflation
rate in 1977 there was a huge frost in
Brazil I have a chapter on it called the
black frost in 1975 and it has a
cumulative effect because it didn't
really affect the crop in 75 it affected
the next few years and so in 1977 the
price went way up by the way every time
that the price has gone way up in in the
United States we have congressional
hearings this happened in 1912 1950 1954
and 1977 where it seems to me a
tremendous waste of our taxpayers money
and our politicians ire if coffee were
grown in the United States we wouldn't
have had these these hearings but we
would say you know this is a communist
plot or this is the Latin American
manipulators they're they're doing this
to us on purpose and facts when the
price went up for the first time it
would actually allow the people who were
working on the coffee farms to be paid
something decent of course not all of
them were because if the if there were
large plantations owned by not very nice
people which they often were they
wouldn't they wouldn't pay substantially
more to the workers even when they could
they would simply take the money and go
to Paris and have a good time you got as
far as that Roberto dobichon and El
Salvador and
I didn't have a relative that's involved
and or somebody was in the government
with him down there involved in coffee
yes the co-founder of the Rana Party
I was named Ricardo Vall vda so and he
turned out to be our our guide for I was
on a trip with the Specialty Coffee
Association and stop you just asked what
is that especially Coffee Association oh
the Specialty Coffee Association of
America it was founded in 1981 and it
was part of this whole sort of
resurgence of rediscovery of good coffee
and they started to call gourmet coffee
specialty coffee it's grown in
importance to it accounts for about 20%
of the coffee in the United States so
you're there on a trip that they put
together I was there for three of those
countries I mentioned with them and then
Guatemala and Costa Rica I was on my own
so what did you find the arena party
chairman has a coffee plantation yes
he's an interesting guy he grew up in
the United States actually and then he
went back to El Salvador and although I
certainly don't agree with the the
politics of the arena party I liked him
personally and I talked to him at a
great length he was shot and nearly
killed during an election campaign he
insists that he was not involved in any
of the death squad activity which dobri
song was associated or was he certainly
accused of being associated with and I
simply don't know but it was very
interesting that trip the day after
talking to him about nearly being killed
we crossed the border into Nicaragua and
there was a big party at the home of
general la caja he was the head of the
Nicaraguan army at his huge coffee
plantation I mean coffee is very much
involved
in the politics down there and he had
been the second-in-command behind
umberto Ortega during the Sandinista
revolution and he was very open about
how the Sandinistas we had this image I
don't know what your politics are I'm
basically sort of a liberal type person
always had been I protested the war in
Vietnam and I was not in favor of our
policy towards the Sandinistas but I
think we tended to romanticize the
Sandinistas and it turns out that they
ruined the coffee industry they were not
good for it at all they were these urban
Marxist intellectuals who didn't know
what they were doing and this guy that I
was the general said sure
first we nationalized Somozas
plantations but then we didn't know how
to run them and the people who had been
working on the plantations were all
going over to the Contras because they
weren't made they were starving to death
they weren't making a living so we gave
them little pieces of land and said here
this is your coffee plot here's a gun
protect it they said we didn't give a
damn whether they actually grew coffee
or not and in fact you know they didn't
know what they were doing and so it's
taken years for the Nicaraguans to come
back now you dedicate the book to Alfred
Peet coffee curmudgeon supreme who is
Alfred Peet Alfred Peet is a Dutch
immigrant to this country he came to San
Francisco in 1955 after let's just back
up his father was a Dutch roaster so he
learned to roast coffee from his dad but
his father was one of these sort of
fathers who never really approved of his
son Alfred it turns out had a learning
disability so he didn't do very well in
school but he loves the smell of coffee
and he loved to help his father but he
could never please him
so after World War two during which
alfred was interned in a german labour
camp he worked for his father briefly
but then he fled and he worked in
Sumatra and Java in the tea industry
primarily spent a little time in New
Zealand and then he ended up in the 50s
in San Francisco where he worked for a
coffee importer and he was appalled by
the quality of the coffee beans that he
was supplying to places like Hills
brothers and Folgers and he said this is
terrible then they laid him off and in
1966 he decided that he would start his
own coffee house he would import only
the finest beans he would roast them to
within an inch of their life with this
trademark dark roast that he developed
and he opened Pete's coffee in 1966 in
Berkeley and it quickly became developed
a cult following
I found it amusing because I've gotten
to know Alfred pretty well now and he
told me that the hippies used to come
into his store and he you know it's very
straight-laced and very demanding and he
didn't like them sitting in his place
and being smelly and messy so he took
the stools out he had six stools and
then they sat on the floor and but he
would have people lined up around the
corner and he really is the father of
the specialty coffee movement the people
who started Starbucks were inspired
directly by him as were many other
people around the country George Howell
who began the coffee connection in
Boston was inspired by Alfred Peet many
many other people were to who owns
Pete's today Jerry Baldwin owns peace
today Jerry was one of the three people
who started Starbucks in 1971 these are
three hippies who wanted to get decent
coffee to Seattle when they first
started what was it it was not a coffee
house the way that we know it they
primarily were selling whole
beans fresh roasted whole beans and they
wanted people to go home and grind them
and brew their own coffee would that
always be Arabica oh yes they have never
have allowed one bean of robusta in
Starbucks and there still is not one
beam of robusta in Starbucks but what
happened with Starbucks is that plastics
salesman named Howard shools joined them
in the early 80s because he he couldn't
he couldn't figure out why he was
telling so many of these thermoses with
a little drip attachment so that you
could drip the coffee directly into a
thermos - this little tiny place in
Seattle and he went out and he was just
struck by their passion for what they
were doing and he took a pay cut and
moved across the country and joined them
then they sent him to Italy to some sort
of house wares convention Jules Schultz
and he was blown away by the espresso
bars there were 1,500 espresso bars in
Milan alone and by the theater of the
barista who was you know pulling a shot
of espresso while he was steaming with
the other hand while he was conversing
with a customer that he knew and he and
Schultz thought this is theater this is
wonderful this is what Starbucks should
be doing and so he went back and tried
to convince Jerry and his partners and
they did allow him to have a little
espresso bar in a corner it was very
successful but it wasn't what they
wanted to do they didn't want to be in
the business of making cappuccinos and
whatever and so Schultz went off on his
own started something called ilzor
nollie which was an unfortunate name
that nobody could pronounce and had no
idea what it meant and it means daily it
was the name of the daily paper in Italy
and about that time Baldwin had the
opportunity to buy Pete's which to him
was you know the you know oh my god I
can own Pete's
so he did and he sort of got stretched
then and he eventually sold Starbucks to
Schultz who had the vision to take it to
what it is today you point out in here
that although we all know the name star
bucks that there's more coffee sold
probably through Dunkin Donuts and
there's Starbucks yeah
Dunkin Donuts has something like 5500
outlets and they've always they've never
used robusta beans either I think they
deserve a lot of credit for maintaining
fairly high standards of quality they
don't roast their own coffee it's all
you know sort of subcontracted for them
but I like Dunkin Donuts by the way do
you have a favorite coffee yourself well
we mentioned La Moneda I really like it
I've become real fun lately of coffee
from Sulawesi also known as Celebes
colosi basically asking somebody who
knows about coffee what their favorite
coffee is it's sort of frustrating it's
sort of like asking a wine connoisseur
what's your favorite wine it depends on
your mood it depends on the time of the
day there are a lot of fine coffees out
there Alfred Peet for instance when he's
asked that he likes blends it's very
rare to find one origin that has full
body and the aroma that you want and the
acidity that you want and it's so
somebody who knows what they're doing
can can blend varieties from different
places you suggested the Revolution and
the United States or before the United
States might have started over coffee
well it started over tea as we all know
with the Boston Tea Party and I was you
know I thought this was a myth that the
Boston Tea Party really had anything to
do with what we drink now but it did I
found John Adams writing to Abagail
saying it's unpatriotic now to drink tea
and I'm going to have to live without it
the Continental Congress passed a law
against drinking tea so they started
drinking more and more coffee of course
we're very pragmatic here in America and
so it turns out that during this time
period the Brazilians were growing more
and more coffee and it was closer to us
it was cheaper so that's another reason
that we went for call
in a big way how much did coffee in the
United States military during World War
two have to do with the American use of
the drink well you know we call coffee
cup of joe now and that came out of
world war ii GI Joe became so closely
identified with his coffee most of which
was instant and and dreadful I have a
wonderful bill Mauldin cartoon in there
where there's a soldier who's got piles
of matches all over the ground and he's
telling somebody in a Jeep says I ain't
worth the Dern in the morning without my
cup a hot cup of coffee he's trying to
heat it with matches but yeah they lived
off coffee during World War two what's
the first instant coffee in the world
well it was probably G Washington coffee
there was a guy named George Washington
who was actually Belgian and he invented
instant coffee while he was living in
Guatemala then he moved to the United
States and started putting it out but
there were a number of people who
claimed to have had the first instant
coffee was around the turn of the
century
what about cafe hog went from Germany
that's decaffeinated coffee and this guy
also invented Sanka they called it that
comes from salt coffee
you know without coffee in French his
name was Ludwig rose alias he was
convinced that his father had died
because he drank too much coffee which
is questionable but he invented
decaffeination process around 1906 or so
and there's the other German Hermann is
it's how do you pronounce that silicon
now I'm not sure the the whole chapter
is devoted to him Oh Herman silicon I'm
sorry yes I was I was trying to think of
somebody in Germany yeah he was a German
immigrant I loved him too he was he was
sort of the opposite of Joel chic he was
not a not a particularly nice man he was
very arrogant and he saved the
Brazilians with this valorisation scheme
by coming up with a seventy-five million
pound
loan to help the Brazilians buy up their
own coffee and warehouse it and
artificially keep the price up
valorisation that word comes up a lot in
your book what's it mean what it means
just what I said it means taking it
means basically giving value to the
coffee that's left by trying to hold
coffee off of the market where'd the
idea come from originally they
originally it came from somebody in
Brazil but it was Herman silken an
American immigrant he was an immigrant
to America who had become a very
powerful coffee importer for a firm
called Crossman and silken who came up
with the money to help them actually
pull this off and he did so by extorting
a lot of the money for himself he became
a multi-millionaire as I told you we had
government hearings over this in 1912
and they were infuriated at silk'n
particularly he he had maintained his
German citizenship he had this huge
estate in baden-baden where he would
retire periodically and where he went
permanently during World War one and
they wanted to throw him in jail and I
quoted his appearance during a committee
hearing and he just thumbed his nose at
them and he was very convincing
he said if I had not done this the price
of coffee would be even higher than it
is now and they said what are you
talking about and he said because what
would have happened would have been you
would have had a revolution people down
there would have you know overthrown the
government and you wouldn't have had any
coffee growing and the price would have
gone sky-high and he may be right he was
an interesting character very arrogant
another subject another footnote page
313 you write one unusual indication of
America's newborn interest in quality
coffee made the news in 1975 on a judge
federal judge in Suffolk County New York
asked a deputy sheriff to buy him a cup
of coffee from a refreshment truck
parked outside the court
outraged by the awful brew the judge
ordered the vendor handy cuffed and
brought into his chambers where the
judge screamed at him releasing him only
after he promised never again to serve
poor coffee it's a true story it's a
true story it got the judge thrown off
the bench by the way it did yeah
federal judge yeah yeah he didn't get
away with it
but I thought it was a funny story that
he felt so strongly about his coffee
that he threw the guy did he lose his
job yeah he lost his job because of it I
didn't include that in the book but yes
that is what happened that brings me to
a question that because you do talk
about in here what's the worst cup of
coffee you've ever had well I said in
the book that the worst cup of coffee I
had was at a little breakfast place and
at a tea a Costa Rica which is the you
know the heart of the coffee growing
region I've had a lot of bad coffee and
in Central America there's there's an
irony to be to this it's very difficult
generally to find a good cup of coffee
where they grow the best coffee in the
world because they export all of it and
they keep the worst beans for themselves
in general so it's difficult to find
good coffee there that's one that's
another reason you mentioned the cafe
Brit that I was impressed by them they
managed it used to be that all the beans
that were kept in Costa Rica were dyed
blue which didn't help them much either
they had a rule that you had to keep 10%
of the beans in the country but they
paid so little for it that companies
would basically go to this auction
they'd sell 2% of the beans they'd buy
their own beans back and they'd do that
five times and say look we sold 10% of
our beans to prevent them from doing
that they would dye the stuff that was
so blue so that no longer happens you
know we started off by talking about
this 800 number that you put in the back
of the book no Brit gob RI TT it just
kept I kept thinking of the difference
today then I'd say it would have been 25
years ago when you call that number do
you give them a credit card yeah
do they do much business this way in the
United States I think they do probably
quite a large business they have
something called the coffee tour which
is you know it's it's a little song and
dance thing it's sort of like what what
coca-cola does with their museum people
pay for the right to be advertised to
essentially and they have a little skit
of where they show you a little bit of
what I tell you in the book about coffee
history and then they sell you their
coffee at the end of it and a lot of a
lot of their customers come back to the
United States and continue to order
their coffee are there a lot of other
places like this now cropping up with
the new modern communications like the
Internet is that is stuff like this all
over the Internet there certainly is a
lot of coffee being sold over the
Internet yes I'm not aware of any other
place that's doing this from origin yet
I hope there will be I think it's a good
thing to happen why well you know I talk
a lot in the book about Fairtrade coffee
that there's basically three kinds of
what I call do good coffee and I don't
mean that in a pejorative sense one of
them is Fairtrade this started in in the
Netherlands about 15 years ago the idea
is if you buy this coffee that has this
little symbol of it on it and says
Fairtrade or max havelaar is what it was
originally called you can be assured
that the people who grew the coffee are
being paid a decent wage for it and they
specifically buy from cooperatives of
small small holders we started doing
that in this country also a place called
equal exchange in Massachusetts
pioneered it and now I think you're
going to hear a lot more about it
because out in California there's a
place called global exchange and they've
teamed up with trans fair and so you're
going to see this Fairtrade mark on more
and more coffee and I think it's a good
idea because you don't have to pay very
much much more for it than you would for
any other good coffee but they are
cutting out
out of the middlemen similarly I think
organic coffee is a good idea even
though it doesn't matter from the
consumer point of view from the health
point of view of the consumer it makes
no difference whether it's organic or
not but the people who are growing the
coffee it makes a great deal of
difference as to whether they're exposed
to pesticides it makes a great deal of
difference to the natural environment
whether it's being exposed to it we
talked earlier about Maxwell House and
Folgers and chase and Sanborn Hills
brothers and all these names that are
very familiar in the United States which
company in the United States makes the
most money or sells the most of coffee
by name that owns all those different
brands today well let's just back up and
say who owns them
Maxwell house is owned Eltham Utley by
Philip Morris Hills brothers chase and
Sanborn all of which sort of were family
businesses that went downhill or had
problems got gobbled up by Nestle where
is that based that's based in
Switzerland Vevey Switzerland and
Folgers is owned by Procter and Gamble
so they're owned by huge corporations
which sells the most of all in the world
I would say that Nestle sells by far
more second would be the Maxwell House
brand because they've bought other
brands in in Germany Folgers is pretty
much limited Procter and Gamble is
pretty much limited to the United States
we're at a time now have another book in
you I suspect so you know what's going
to be about I'm I have some ideas but I
prefer not to talk about till I have a
contract here is the book it's by Mark
Pendergrast based in Vermont
it's called uncommon grounds the history
of coffee and how it transformed our
world and we just scratched the surface
thank you very much thank you